if you look at the history there are
space programs
both russian and american you're going
to find some pretty weird stuff
pretty pretty weird history there lex um
so
you want to get an idea go back to
tchaikowski and read a little bit about
what he has to say
if you look back at the history of our
space programs the viable space programs
are both russian and american
and each has an amazingly
strange history because uh the founders
of the calculations that got us up into
space the rocket scientists basically
were doing some pretty weird rituals and
doing religious things
right they weren't necessarily like jack
parsons on our side
i was out in the desert with people like
elrond hubbard and
doing really intense rituals
believing that they were opening
stargates and things like that okay
that's awesome and they were really
doing that okay
so then you go to um the russian
side and they had a very specific
non-dogmatic according to catholics or
orthodox christianity
idea of what christianity was and they
believed that they were interacting with
angels
okay non-human intelligences so if you
look back and you see muses
you know you can contextualize them
within this tradition
and so when i started to talk to people
who were actually in
the space program and who were in these
programs that
now the government has said oh yeah we
do have those programs
and they have the same belief structures
they believe that they were also in
contact with these non-human
intelligences
and they were getting what they called
downloads of information and creating
sometimes
with tyler d in my book creating
technologies
that were real and they were selling
them on nasdaq for
you know a lot of money like you know
say 100 million dollars or something
like that
undisclosed amounts um but a lot and
these things are viable technologies
that we use now and
and they make our lives better and we
progress as a species because of them
now that has nothing to do with the
scientific method
as much as i know as much as anybody's
going to get angry at me for saying that
but you know
sorry those were strange encounters
that created our ability to go into
space
i don't know if they're real or not but
these people believe they were real
right so there's a they have a power in
actually having an impact in this world
in um
in inspiring humans to create
technology which enable us to do things
we haven't been able to do before
yeah and these i like how we we're
putting like
angels alien life forms
aliens and technology all in the
non-human intelligence camp which i i
really like that because this
that's very true it's this other
source of wisdom intelligence
maybe a connection to the mysterious yes
i was really surprised by it
you